- All right, y'all.
We always like to wrap
up with something fun.
And today, well, this may
be my all-time favorite one.
This is "#What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music playing)
(audience applauding)
I'm so excited about this.
You may remember,
there was this really big
football game a couple days ago
surrounded by a concert
that was incredible.
It was predicted to be close, y'all.
And it, well, it sure delivered on that.
I happened to make a little wager
on the game last week against
ESPN's Stephen A. Smith.
Let's just take a quick look at that.
- Well, what bet you want?
- [Kelly] Okay.
Okay.
- I'll bet Kelly Clark.
- Okay, wait wait.
- Wait. Wait.
- All right, I'll do that.
I'll do that.
- If the Chiefs...
If the Chiefs win
you have to come on here
and say you love the Dallas Cowboys.
(audience booing)
(Kelly laughing)
And if the Eagles win,
I have to come on your
show and do something...
- [Stephen] That's right.
- embarrassing.
- Let, let, let's do it this way.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'll take that back.
- Okay.
Okay.
What do I have to do?
- If the Eagles win this Super Bowl,
you don't have to be a song.
- Okay.
- I want you to sing a tune dedicated
to Stephen A. Smith, The Straight Shooter.
(Kelly laughing and applauding)
(audience applauding)
- I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Oh my God.
Come on, Chiefs!
(scattered laughter)
Do this for me!
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Well, we all know how that worked out.
I won!
(audience cheering)
I am so excited.
Now it's time for The
Straight Shooter to deliver.
We have Stephen A. Smith
on the line right now.
What's up, Stephen?
(Kelly laughing and applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
How are you?
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God.
That's what your face looked
like when we were in the suite.
So by coincidence-
- It's unbelievable.
- I can't even, can you
even believe when you walked
in this week, I was like,
"We're in the same suite?"
What, we were, they put
us in the same suite
- [Stephen] I know.
at the Super Bowl.
- [Kelly] And, I know, Oh my God.
So freaking funny.
So you, were you freaking out
as that game clock was winding down?
- Yeah, and I was looking
at you like, "Ohh!"
- I was, I was.
I thought the Eagles had 'em.
I mean, they still went up
24 to 14 in the first half.
- [Kelly] I know.
I was like, "This is good.
I'm gonna have Kelly
Clarkson sing a song to me."
I mean, this is beautiful.
And the next thing I know, you know,
everything fell apart, you know.
(Kelly laughing)
I didn't expect that.
It kind of caught me by surprise.
But it's all right.
I mean, you got the best of me.
I mean, it's embarrassing.
I mean, I'm a sports
analyst losing sports bet
to a premier singer and talk show host.
But you know, I mean, these
kind of things happen.
I just have to deal with it.
I have to take it.
- Oh my God.
I gotta be honest with you.
No one, and I know saw
that coming, but I will
tell you, my favorite part
of the entire Super Bowl
even topping, 'cause I
loved Rihanna and Stapleton,
everybody, Babyface, everybody.
Shirley, everybody did such a great job.
The players, everybody.
But my favorite part of the Super Bowl
was turning around and looking at you
right before the Chiefs won.
(Kelly laughing)
- I mean, it was, it felt so good.
And I just couldn't
stop laughing about it.
I was like, "I don't know
how this is happening,
but I'm so happy."
And is there anything
else that you want to say
before you announce
your new favorite team?
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm not announcing a new favorite team.
That is not the bet we had.
The Dallas Cowboy, no,
I'm not doing it, Kelly.
I don't remember it this way.
- [Stephen] But I will say this.
- [Stephen] I will say this.
I...
- Get it out.
- Hold on, hold on.
I...
I love The Cowboys!
- Oh my God!
(audience cheering)
- I've said it, okay?!
- You heard it here.
- [Stephen] I've said it, all right.
(Kelly and Stephen laughing)
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
I love you so much!
Hey, you, you owned it
and you, you did it.
You followed through with the bet.
That's a man of your word.
I'm just saying.
Cowboys lover, Stephen
A. Smith, everybody.
(Kelly laughing and applauding)
(audience applauding)
Oh my God, I love it so much.
I'm liking your post right now
because it's the greatest bet ever.
Okay, everybody.
Stephen's book is called Straight Shooter.
- This is torture.
It's out now.
You can also see him mornings on ESPN
as the host of First Take
and listen to his podcast,
No Mercy, wherever you get your podcast.
I love him.
Y'all got to check him out
if you don't know him already
which you probably do.
But now's the time when
we usually give our guest
a thousand dollars
courtesy of our season long
partner, Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But, Stephen's doing
all right for himself,
you know, except for losing the bet.
(Kelly and audience chuckling)
He said it on my show.
(Kelly laughing)
Okay.
So today it's going to
someone in the audience.
The check is taped beneath
someone chair so start
looking for a thousand dollars.
- Come on.
(drum roll)
- (singsongy) Who's got it?
Yeah?
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music playing)
(Kelly applauding)
Oh my gosh.
You literally just went, "Whaat."
- I was like, "What is it
supposed to feel like?"
And I'm, "Like this?"
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
What's your name?
- I'm Alex Lee.
Hi Kelly Clarkson.
- What?
Hi.
I love your response.
It was amazing.
What do you think you'll
spend the money on?
- Bad decisions, I don't know.
(audience cheering)
- Enjoy!
- [Alex] Thank you.
- Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Evangeline Lilly, Jonathan
Davis, Dr. Terrence Ferguson,
Dr. Vernard Hodges, Kelly
Gray, and of course my Cowboys.
Loving man, Stephen A. Smith.
Have a great day off.
If it's not, try and change it.